terrence malick one of the only people
in the industry that some people refer
to as one of the best directors live
while other people refer to him as
someone who would be excellent at
directing National Geographic animal
documentaries to the Wonder is a film
that I actually saw at TIFF last
September I have been holding off on
reviewing it until it was closer to the
release date I've had thoughts about the
film I wrote a review for it that's on
movie Dexcom Terrence Malick was of
course not at the screening and TIFF he
is very very private he does not like to
have pictures taken of him he's very
reclusive it makes his films and then he
kind of goes into an igloo somewhere and
hides and you don't really hear much
about him but Rachel McAdams was at the
TIFF premiere which was pretty cool
and it's pretty cool to see the film in
the Princess of Wales Theatre which does
see 2,000 people it's very difficult to
describe the plot of this film very
similar to the way it was hard to
describe tree of life in this film there
is a couple who's having hardships in
their marriages the husband perhaps has
a brief fling with another woman there's
also a priest played by Javier Bardem
who's contemplating his faith
essentially the film is a string of
montages where the characters are being
very thoughtful they're thinking a lot
they're looking at beautiful scenery a
lot of the dialogue is whispered or told
as if it is a poem no I like tree of
life
I didn't flat-out love it or anything
but I appreciated the film it was
visually well told it had good
performances and despite the fact that
certain story elements of it were
extremely confusing to me I still found
the film to be pretty ambitious and I
liked it for that too the wonder however
clearly suffered from quite a bit of
production issues especially
post-production you can really tell this
film has been chopped and cut and edited
and changed entire actors have been
removed from the movie certain story
elements have been jumbled and resore
'td it's painfully obvious as you watch
this film that the director and the
editor and the stars all had a
completely different idea of the type of
film they were making see Ben Affleck is
doing virtually no press for this film
do you know why because no joke the man
has about five lines in the entire movie
and I mean that and most of them are
whispered and barely audible at all
because the music or someone else's
dialogue is overlapping his rarely ever
does the poor man even get a close-up at
all he's generally
started as a prop the film seems to be
resented around Olga's character his
wife it is very clear that the film
perhaps was told through a much more
conventional narrative at least
conventional in a Terrence Malick way
where it's definitely unconventional but
I mean that it was clear as they set out
to make this film that there were story
elements that were conceivable as a
beginning a middle and an end this film
is not like that at all and where
sometimes that's very impressive and
extremely refreshing to see a film that
is different from others with this film
I found that it really hurt the movie
because not only was I in a constant
state of confusion in regards to where
the characters were what timeline this
was it's very clear that throughout the
film terrence malick as a filmmaker was
extremely distracted and very unclear
about how to tell this story which shows
in the way that it was edited in post
because so many things were changed and
entire actors and story elements
completely removed there are shots in
this film where Ben Affleck might be
walking in his backyard having a
conversation with someone and maybe a
flock of birds happens to fly over him
and the camera will literally just pan
up and follow the birds off into the
woods for no discernible reason other
than look there's some birds he's an
extremely impressive visual director and
this film looks gorgeous it really does
and it sounds great too but from a story
perspective there is literally nothing
to latch on to in this movie most of the
film is Olga's character just dancing
around in fields and I'm not
exaggerating count how many times she
goes out in the field and twirls around
and dances and you see the sunset behind
her you can tell that actors like Javier
Bardem and Ben Affleck were virtually
wasted and even Rachel McAdams has maybe
like ten minutes in the entire film and
I guarantee that she filmed more than
that I'm kind of upset about the way
Malick treats his actors and I don't
really like that you sign on for a movie
you're interested in this script and
you're giving your all to a performance
and when it gets to the editing Bay even
though it is technically his movie the
way he cuts out actors without their
consent is incredibly rude to me he did
this to Adrian Brody who was essentially
the main character of the Thin Red Line
and he did not find out that he was
almost entirely removed from that film
until he was at the premiere of The Thin
Red Line and a report
asked him how he felt about the fact
that he was removed from the movie and
this is something that Malick does to
his actors and I really don't approve of
it and I find that it really harmed this
movie and for that reason I'm not going
to recommend seeing to the wonder
despite the fact that it's a
beautiful-looking movie it sounds great
and the performances that are there seem
like they are an actor who is trying to
reach for something but it's very clear
that that actor was invested in a story
that terrence malick did not care about
because eventually he removed it from
the film and so the performances and the
story that is there don't mesh at all
I'm going to give to the Wonder a see
it's a great looking film and Terrence
Malick fans will appreciate that but the
performers are all wasted and the story
there's nothing there to latch on to so
if you see the movie I'd like to know
what you think thanks a lot for watching
guys and as always if you liked this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes